[Music]
you are watching the press preview first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of wales online
ruth monsolski and the political editor
of the sun
harry cole they'll be with us right
through until
midnight and they are smiling about that
give us a smile
yes they are so let's see what's on the
front pages of some of those papers now
for the metro leads on team gb's olympic
success
ministers urge caution as covid cases
plunge again that's in the guardian
also a picture of an emotional tom daley
on the front of the telegraph new plans
to make burglars wear tags
after they're released from jail to try
and tackle reoffending
the times follows its main headline the
prime minister gets tough on burglars
another crime story in the express their
own investigation revealing
more than 20 000 officers were assaulted
during the pandemic
and the ft reports that the u.s
government has blocked an attempt to
create the world's biggest
insurance broker
so taking us through the newspapers
tonight ruth masalski
and harry cole good evening welcome to
you both
let's start with you first of all let's
have a look at the guardian
and uh their front page there ministers
urge
caution as covid cases plunge
again uh the government's uh somehow
sort of rowing back on
you know previous thoughts of that
freedom freedom day aren't they
well it's interesting so number 10
they're here saying that you know while
infections are at their lowest level for
three weeks
it's still you know we're not out of the
woods and i think the devolved
administrations are going to be
delighted to hear this sort of cautious
note from whitehall and
let's not forget the market in
particular here in wales has been
extremely cautious in some ways he's
been criticized for that
very early on and actually that's and
proved to be
a very successful tactic for him that
hasn't always been the case coming from
downing street and actually to hear this
note of caution that
we're not out of the woods we don't know
what the effect yet because this data
doesn't include the um release of
restrictions in england on july 19th
so there's still a lot to look at and it
could be two or three weeks where we'd
put another full picture in terms of
cases and infections from that um
freedom day release and so there's still
plenty of questions to
to ask and i think it's quite nice to
hear that turn of caution coming from
down the street today
yes harry and the the article also uh
pointing to the fact that that experts
um point to a number of coveted 19
patients in hospital in england which
has passed 5000
for the first time since mid-march and
that as a sign
of the pandemic not being over
yeah no i don't think anyone thinks it's
over however i think everyone is
fascinated by what we've seen in the
last six days
um just a week ago um i was sitting in
this very spot talking to
your colleague uh and it didn't look
anything like this but then
in a weird way we've all been looking at
the covert dashboard
each day at four o'clock when it gets
updated sort of willing it to be going
the right way
and it has it's down fifty percent in
the week
it's down it's down more so i think it's
about 59
since that peak we saw on the about the
16th of july
where there were 60 000 cases and it was
a bit baffled there's lots of uh
lots of sort of you know scientists are
out in the airwaves today saying it
could be
this like the schools are not uh the
schools are no longer
in its kids no longer at school it could
be the fact that that means that
fewer lateral flow tests are being done
it could be a knock on from the euros we
saw uh scotland's rates start to fall as
soon as they crashed out very early i
should add
in that competition um or it could just
be the sunshine or
fingers crossed it is the sort of
mythical state
of the bug running out of people to
infect by hitting this massive wall of
vaccinated people over 80 of the uk now
has been jabbed with at least one jab
and those second doses are catching up
so
i think they're absolutely right to be
cautious but i think we're also
well within our rights to be crossing
our fingers and and praying that this is
going the right way and we just want to
see that
that green light on the dashboard light
up as it did this week
just stay there and and translate into a
decline in hospitalizations
as we all know in a lag of a couple of
weeks yes no that's what we're
all praying for let's move on to the
telegraph
and they're saying over half of coveted
hospital cases test positive
after admission uh ruth take us into
this this story this element of the
story
this is a telegraph story from
tomorrow's front which is that
it the the question here is whether the
the level of pressure on the nhs is
currently being overstated
and so this is leaked data to the
telegraph and it's saying that for
english nhs trust just forty four
percent of people request
uh has been hospitalized with cover to
test deposit before they were admitted
to hospital
and we've always known all along that
you know the questions about when people
have it is hospital contributing to it
that's why let's not forget lots of
hospitals are saying please don't come
unless it's absolutely necessary
um but this you know i think my worry
with this sort of story is that right
now it's such it feels like
such a tipping point um and saying
things like this is overstating
uh or could be overstating the pressure
on nhs sort of is quite a dangerous
narrative
um in terms of uh the
anti-vaxx movement as you know the
scenes we've seen all over the world
here in cardiff at the weekend we had
protesters
outside the first minister's private
home and he doesn't have an official
residence he has a private house and the
the
protesters were outside there which was
a move that was universally condemned
but
i think my con my concern with sort of
saying
actually maybe the nhs isn't as in as
much struggle and trouble as
as maybe it appears is um it could sort
of feed into that
dangerous narrative at a time when that
cautious note has been uh
espoused from down history harry does
this sort of headline worry you that
that people might not uh
present a hospital because they're
they're terrified of what might happen
once they're there
yeah no that has been um an overwhelming
problem for the last 18 months that
people have been unable or unwilling to
go to hospital we've read
awful horrific case studies who real
real people who have died at home with
heart attacks and
various other ailments because they
didn't want to go into hospital but i
think you know this story
yeah i have no doubt that the the
sourcing in the in the telegraph's
health editor
you know she's had a very good covered
pandemic if you can put it in that
fashion of
stuff that seems to be bang on the money
over the course of the last 18 months
but at the same time obviously you've
got other nhs leaders out in other other
papers today and
and into tomorrow i expect saying look
actually it is starting to tick up
but you know again i go back to that
point of you know
look at the numbers the data we have now
um you know
at this stage of the pandemic far out
outscores any data we had
at you know any other stage in this
pandemic and you know there are 5 000
people now nudging into hospital
yes some of them probably did catch it
there rather than being admitted with
covered
but at the peak of the of the of the
second wave certainly when we know
once again we all stayed at home to
relieve that pressure on the nhs
you know there were 35 000 people in
hospital with kobits so
you know the numbers are quite stark
it's starkly different
yeah should we talk about some some good
news let's have a look at the metro
front page and although he's in tears
this is a happy story
tom daley there pictured on on the front
of the metro emotional
and his gold medal that he received
today ruth
yeah i'm sure i'm not i wasn't the only
person sat this morning my pajamas
feeling completely inadequate as i ate
my uh
cereal watching tom daley and and then
matty liebering had a gold medal
and it was an incredible thing to watch
and i think you know as someone pointed
out on twitter not only afterwards let's
not forget tom daley's only 27
um for what he's done today and the
journey he's been on that i think most
of us would probably feel like we've
joined along with him on it's incredible
and it's a beautiful picture
um and he's used his platform in the
most fantastic way you know when he came
out he did it publicly and he said
and he was doing that to help others and
today he's done that again
and which is just absolutely brilliant
you know his quotes say i'm proud to say
i'm a gay man and also an olympic
champion
he's on the front page of newspapers
here and hopefully in other places
around the world
and that could only be a great thing if
as he said if you're um
an lgbt young person or someone who's
not come out yet to see that sort of
role model plus is all the front pages
and it's it's just a brilliant brilliant
story
yeah and as you say only still only 27
it's hard to to to imagine that he
started his olympic career when he was
13 harry it's astonishing
all the way back in 2008 all those
nearly also you know it was nearly there
he got a couple of bronzers
he was you know a superstar of london
but you know you could see the pain on
his face when he didn't get there
get the goal he wanted and he's finally
there and you know what what a what an
inspiring role model we've been treated
to some pretty
seriously inspiring role models this
summer uh in the sporting uh in the
sporting world but you know a man
standing there proud gay man winning for
britain knocking the chinese out the
park
and crying to god save the queen i mean
how anyone could not be moved by that uh
by that image then i don't know i don't
know how
half expecting you to stand up there
ruth and harry thanks so much for the
moment uh we're going to take a break
coming up
the government's plan to tag burglars
after they've been released
from jail we'll be discussing that and
more after the break to stay with us
[Music]
welcome back here you're watching the
press preview
still with me the political editor of
wales online ruth masalski and the
political editor of the sun
harry cole welcome back to you both
let's have a look at the
telegraph front page and this
story about uh what to do with with
burglars once they've
served i think a sentence of at least a
a year
uh being proposed that they wear 24-hour
tags ruth
yeah so this is the big announcement
coming from down the street tomorrow
based on the front page of the telegraph
from their um
times and so it's it's the prime
minister's latest sort of crackdown on
on criminals
uh something that he's talked about
obviously a lot since his election
campaign
um i think this the this is a a pilot
that's going to be rolled out to further
forces as it's already been
in six police forces it's going out to
the 13. and the idea is that police will
be able to check the movements if
someone's
tag is on constantly they'll be able to
check the movements of where they were
when a crime was committed
and and tell you those two things and it
also promises things like named police
officer in every area
um there's talk of it changing uh the
um stop and search um so it's also the
big
latest big ticket item coming from
downing street i mean
i think the question that came through
my mind i read this telegram pages
how's this going to be excuse me upon
police um we
we know that um relations between prince
patel and the police federation is
a a low point to say the least
and we know there's not enough police
officers on the streets and boris
johnson's promised twenty thousand more
and we're still
you know waiting for all those to be
there he says that this is going to give
the police and
criminal justice system that the tools
they need to hammer those
who persist in breaking the law but i
think i imagine a lot of police officers
reading this and asking
how on earth are they going to be able
to do it yes they're talking about uh
increasing
stop-and-search powers uh as well and
presumably to tag all of these
freed uh burglars it's gonna cost an
awful lot of money to monitor the tags
and
let them provide them yeah so this is a
classic sort of boris big picture here's
the ideas it's uh there are some
elements of it are i think are really
interesting
there's um something called drink tanks
which um
monitor sort of um criminals who have
been released from prison possibly
before the end of their sentence will be
tagged with these
um these tags that monitor their sweat
every 30 minutes to
take samples of alcohol to stop them
drinking once they've been released
because
home office tonight is saying that 39 of
violent crimes are linked to alcohol
so there are some really interesting
things in there that sort of feels a
little bit like it's all being sort of
bundled up
to be announced at the same time as the
as the police recruitment numbers are
coming
later this week and you get the feeling
they're probably quite good for the
government
um on their way to their target of
twenty thousand
police recruits i think the really
interesting political bit of this though
tomorrow
is the sort of final nail in the coffin
of um theresa may's legacy she spent
a decade as home secretary um
restricting stop and search
and on the steps of down the street she
said you know it was unjust it was you
it was it was unfair and discriminatory
and boris johnson within days of getting
into number 10 to replace her
began to unpick that and allowed police
forces to
roll out stop and search something
called section 60 powers which gives
them
more freedom to do stop research
particularly in the aftermath of a
violent incident so in the aftermath of
the stabbing
they're able to search more people to
either try and find weapons
or to stop reprisal attacks and that's
um been sort of being piloted ever since
boris johnson took over in 2019
and he's going to be now rolled out
permanently across the country
um so i think they'll be you know
obviously there'll be a row about police
funding the police pay which you know
they're not getting to the end at the
same pay rise the nhs
uh nurses are so there's a bit of
grumbling there but it'd be interesting
to see if
if enough there's enough meat in this in
this document in this policy blitz
tomorrow
to to see whether that can sort of cut
through the the noise of
a negotiation yes please very
interesting that the pretty patella is
quoted as saying that stop and search is
a
vital tool a complete change for me as
you say
the administration of theresa may ruth
and harry thank you